aproximadamente entre 50 y 70 mil personas,
que viven en esta comunidad de edificios de varias plantas
construidos por ellos mismos
donde hasta tres generaciones viven en una estructura.
Mientras que estas viviendas que construyen ellos mismos
carecen aparentemente de planificación o diseño formal,
el que cada familia se especialice en una forma de reciclaje
significa que el piso bajo de cada edificio
se reserva a actividades relacionadas con la basura
y el piso superior se dedica a la vivienda.
Me parece increíble ver
que estos montones y montones de basura
son invisibles para la gente que vive allí,
como este hombre tan distinguido que posa
con toda esta basura desparramada detrás de él,
o como estos dos hombres jóvenes que están sentados
y charlando entre toneladas de basura.
Mientras que para la mayoría de nosotros, vivir entre
estos montones y montones de basura
puede parecer totalmente inhabitable,
para los del Zabbaleen, esto es
un tipo diferente de normalidad.
En todos estos lugares de los que he hablado hoy,
lo que encuentro fascinante es que en realidad
lo normal no existe,
y esto prueba que la gente es capaz de adaptarse
a cualquier tipo de situación.
Durante el día, es bastante normal
encontrarse con una pequeña celebración
en la calle, como esta fiesta de compromiso.
En esta tradición, la que pronto será la novia
muestra todas sus pertenencias,
que pronto entregará a su nuevo marido.
Una reunión como esta
ofrece tal yuxtaposición
donde se muestra todo lo nuevo
y se utiliza toda la basura
como los útiles para la demostración de sus nuevos accesorios del hogar.
Como Makoko y la Torre de David,
por todo el Zabbaleen se pueden encontrar
los mismos servicios que en cualquier vecindario público.
Hay tiendas, cafés
restaurantes, y la comunidad
es esta comunidad de cristianos coptos,
así que podrán encontrar una iglesia,
incluido un gran número de iconografías religiosas
por toda la zona,
así como los servicios del día a día
como las tiendas de reparación electrónica,
los barberos, todo.
La visita a las casas de los Zabbaleen
está también llena de sorpresas.
Mientras que desde el exterior,
estas casas son como cualquier otra estructura informal
de la ciudad, cuando uno entra,
se encuentra con todo tipo de decisiones de diseño
y de decoración de interiores.
A pesar de las limitaciones de espacio y dinero,
las casas de la zona están diseñadas
con cuidado y detalle.
Cada apartamento es único,
y su individualidad cuenta la historia
de las circunstancias y valores de cada familia.
Muchos de ellos se toman muy en serio
sus hogares y espacios interiores,
y ponen en los detalles
mucho trabajo y cuidado.
Los espacios comunes también reciben la misma atención,
en ellos las paredes se decoran con motivos de falso mármol.
Pero a pesar de esta elaborada decoración,
a veces estas viviendas reciben
usos muy inesperados,
como esta casa que me llamó la atención
mientras que el barro y la hierba se salían
literalmente por debajo la puerta de entrada.
Cuando me invitaron a entrar, resulta que esta vivienda del quinto piso
se estaba transformando completamente en una granja,
en la que había seis o siete vacas pastando
en lo que podría haber sido la sala de estar.
Pues bien, en el apartamento frente al
establo de vacas vive una pareja de recién casados
en el que los vecinos describen
como uno de los mejores apartamentos de la zona.
La atención prestada a este detalle me asombró,
y mientras que el dueño de la vivienda
me guiaba orgulloso por el apartamento,
de suelo a techo, cada elemento estaba decorado.
Pero si no fuera por el olor nauseabundo,
extrañamente familiar, que se filtra constantemente
por el apartamento,
sería fácil olvidar
que uno está junto a un establo de vacas
y encima de un vertedero.
Lo que más me emocionó fue que a pesar
de estas condiciones aparentemente inhóspitas,
me dieron la bienvenida con los brazos abiertos
a una casa hecha con amor, cuidado,
y pasión ilimitada.
Crucemos el mapa hasta China,
a una zona llamada Shanxi, Henan y Gansu.
En una región famosa por la tierra blanda y porosa de la meseta de Loess,
vivían hasta hace poco unos
40 millones de personas en estas casas bajo tierra.
Estas viviendas se llaman yaodongs.
Por medio de esta arquitectura substractiva,
estos yaodongs están construidos literalmente dentro de la tierra.
En estos pueblos pueden ver un paisaje totalmente alterado,
y oculto tras estos montículos de suelo
y estas casas cuadradas, rectangulares
localizadas a 7 metros bajo tierra.
Cuando le pregunté a la gente por qué excavaban
sus casas en la tierra,
se limitaron a decirme que son malos cultivadores
de trigo y de manzanas y que no tenían el dinero
para comprar materiales, por lo que la excavación
resultó ser la forma más lógica de vivir.
De Makoko al Zabbaleen, estas comunidades
se han planteado las tareas de planificación,
diseño y gestión de las comunidades
y vecindarios de varias formas que responden
específicamente a su entorno y circunstancias.
Creados por las personas que de verdad viven,
trabajan y juegan en estos espacios concretos,
estos vecindarios se han diseñado intuitivamente
para sacarle el máximo partido a sus circunstancias.
En la mayoría de estos lugares, la ausencia
de gobierno es completa, dejando a los habitantes
sin otra elección que recuperar materiales encontrados,
y aunque estas comunidades están muy desfavorecidas,
presentan verdaderos ejemplos
de brillantes formas de ingenio,
y demuestran que es cierto que tenemos la capacidad
de adaptarnos a todo tipo de circunstancias.
Lo hace que lugares como la Torre de David
sean particularmente extraordinarios
es esta especie de armazón-esqueleto
que la gente utiliza como base
que pueden aprovechar.
Ahora, imaginen lo que estas comunidades tan ingeniosas
podrían crear por sí mismas,
y lo singulares que serían sus soluciones
si se les proporcionaran infraestructuras básicas
que pudieran aprovechar.
Hoy en día se pueden ver esos grandes proyectos de complejos residenciales
que ofrecen soluciones para la vivienda hechas en serie
para un enorme número de personas.
De China a Brasil, el propósito de estos proyectos
es proporcionar tantas casas como sea posible,
pero son totalmente genéricos
y la verdad es que no son la solución
a las necesidades individuales de la gente.
Me gustaría terminar con una cita
de una amiga mía y fuente de inspiración,
Zita Cobb, la fundadora de la maravillosa
Fundación Shorefast,
con sede en la isla Fogo, en Terranova.
Ella dice que "existe esta plaga de invariabilidad
que está matando la alegría humana",
y estoy totalmente de acuerdo con ella.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)